Grameen dramatic I all right John can
you bring out the first course there's
John Wow okay Alfred is here John what
you got oh these are Queen leaf cutter
ants they're found in Colombia Venezuela
and Brazil okay South America y'all
eatin bugs the aisle Freddy you're fired
they smell like the ropes we're not
gonna smell like anything well you don't
know they might be they smell Rosalie
I've had worse in my milk like a little
coffee bean facing up but it's like what
it looks like it's not bad
they had like a feeling oh no I didn't
you know what it doesn't taste bad it
tastes like bitter chocolates when I
took the first bite it did taste that
corner so I'm like you know what I'll
finally get used to it I like that it
was small like if I was trying to get
the mood quick I'll pop one in I think
I'll eat it again what are some positive
things you can take from that the fact
that it's not here anymore
didn't I fire you it's called balute oh
no it's a delicacy from the Philippines
and there's a baby bird in here
good night I'm not even trying Alfred
boom there's juice there this Oh
literally
[Music]
it honestly tastes like an egg like I
get it yeah it's an egg for me it tastes
like chicken but it's just the look of
it it looks way worse than it tastes
this dish is from Jamaica you know cal
cod soup and these are mole penises he
left that part to the end you were like
oh yeah and then eat this date it's like
just which part of the deck do I want
normally I don't get enjoy it smells
good
listen I'm not gonna lie this smells
delicious I don't think I could take
other things
oh it's spicy John is just laughing John
you think this [ __ ] is funny
Oh hmm that's some good dick yeah very
cool
you got the foreskin we have a soup in
Dominican public car sancocho and it's
basically something just like this this
is like a mellow situation Monroe is a
Mexican soup I'm gonna go home and tell
my boyfriend yo I had dick today I'll be
like julissa you didn't have my dick so
what were you asleep oh I know this one
durian and it's from Southeast Asia you
know that order is strong for some
people it smells really bad but I like
to me that smells really sweet
it's like fermenting fruits and that's
what it gets you're horny because it's
exactly drunk it's very like fleshy
[Music]
no I don't think it's bad I don't know
it was like slimy the texture is a
little weird but like it does it gives
me like mango vibes yeah I think of my
taste buds are different because it
tastes good to me
out of anything I do feel like this will
get me horny too so would you say any of
that worked for you on the contrary I
don't think I'm gonna have sex for a
month I feel like people have to do this
too to get in the mood I'm all for it I
just don't think this works for me
I'm just don't stick to drinking John
get out of here go back to your wife and
kids you don't need to be doing this
you're better than this seriously
[Music]